hello and welcome to gamespot of Thrones
you are watching just a small segment of
a much larger program where we discuss
in depth Game of Thrones season 6
episode 1 the red woman if you'd like to
see the full episode be sure to head to
youtube.com slash gamespot beware of
spoilers in watching this episode though
I kind of Drew some really strange
parallels and you have to promise to
hear me out because it's a really weird
one The Princess Bride so obviously I
don't know if you've seen the movie now
I'm gonna spoil a little bit of it so in
in the movie that's character named
Wesley whoo-hoo gets killed and he's
taken to this miracle miracle max played
by Billy Crystal a miracle max is
basically able to bring Wesley back from
the dead because he's only mostly dead
like he's not fully daddy hasn't been
dead that long and I kind of think that
in this scenario Wesley is Jon Snow and
miracle max is Melisandre but wait
there's more god I hope so no right so
Melisandre she like she keeps putting
all her money all her bets on people
that don't pan out so look at Stannis
she put all her money on Stannis and
then Stannis was just a complete failure
she put all our money on John and then
John ends up getting betrayed by his own
brothers so she's obviously to have
faith in the Lord of Light is kind of
winning and we see in this episode you
sort of seed the real Melisandre you see
her with without her necklace on and
she's like this old saggy lady but in
the princess bride miracle max actually
doesn't want to resurrect Wesley Wesley
because he got fired from his last job
and he he has a real lack of confidence
real crisis of confidence he doesn't
want to do it but then he does do it
because Wesley's only mostly dead so
maybe Melisandre's realized that John is
only mostly dead cuz hasn't been dead
for that long and that she may be can
bring him back also no doesn't also this
always and also there in the standoff
with ser Alliser and Davos Davos
requests and some mutton I'd like some
mutton mutton for the journey and if you
see the princess bride you are
that miracle max is okay in miracle
Max's world the two greatest things one
is love true love the second greatest
thing in his life is a nice MLT mutton
lettuce tomato sandwich where the mutton
is lean okay so basically what I'm
saying is this is a really convoluted
way of saying well as such it's gonna
bring John back also she looked a bit
like Billy Crystal when cheddar old lady
prosthetics on so that's me drop mike I
think you should stick to the r + l
equals J and Clegane both very stupid no
cuz this is my theory I mean what what
you're saying here is that there's some
tropes in this and also Princess Bride
about resurrecting people I think no no
I think they're dropping hints and the
people who've read and seen the princess
bride mm-hmm no because I also want to
point out that i don't know if you've
seen american horror story coven but
there is someone who can resurrect
people in that and she can only do it
when they haven't been dead for very
long guys this is a show like Game of
Thrones the Martin is key okay the
Martin is the case
you